katrin lompscher die linken senatorin
für bauen und mieten in berlin
zurückgetreten
grund dafür sie hat einnahmen von über
15.000 euro nicht versteuert
dabei geht es um aufsichtsrat bezüge aus
2017 und 18 dient nicht in der
steuererklärung auftauchen
bedauerlicherweise musste ich
feststellen dass sich das versäumt habe
sagte lompscher zu bild für die
sozialistin und mit erfinderinnen des
berliner mieten deckels war es das also
und das hat der regierende bürgermeister
michael müller heute dazu gesagt ja ich
bedaure das weil wir eben eine gute
zusammenarbeit hatten in den letzten
jahren und wir haben auch konflikte
miteinander ausgetragen im senat was die
neubauzahlen anbelangt aber wir haben
unter dem strich sehr verlässlich und
konstruktiv zusammengearbeitet aber ich
respektiere auch dass kathrin frey für
sich einfach auch erkannt hat dass es
nicht geht wenn es über jahre eine
steuerschuld gibt man muss dieser sache
nachkommen sie hat dieses fehlverhalten
für sich auch so festgehalten dass sie
gesagt hat dann geht es eben nicht mehr
und das ist auch zu respektieren und zu
würdigen sprechen wir darüber mit ra kam
schröder erst der geschäftsführer des
immobilienunternehmens engel & völkers
herr schröder sie gelten hat großer
kritiker der wohnungspolitik in berlin
was genau werden sie jetzt der senatorin
vor bzw auch den senat
ich habe ich habe es leider nicht mehr
geschafft und bin hier direkt aus dem
urlaub aus dem stand club nach
zugeschaltet der größte vorwurf ist viel
weniger das was sie getan hat ob der
wiegen natürlich seinesgleichen sucht
aber es ist vielmehr das was sie
unterlassen hat zu tun
die zeit wäre einmalig gewesen um
wirklich mit einer konstruktiven
wohnungsbaupolitik den markt langfristig
zu entspannen und sogar dafür zu sorgen
dass die berliner wirklich eigentümer
werden können wir könnten mieter zu
eigentümern machen jetzt hat sie
versäumt und so ist ihr vorwurf oder der
vorwurf den wir machen können eben viel
mehr das was sie nicht getan hat sie ist
keine pause sondern sich auch
verhinderungs senatoren gewesen jetzt
muss man natürlich auch sagen wohnraum
in berlin ist extrem teuer
welche konkreten maßnahmen können denn
zu einer entspannung beitragen
aus unserer sicht wirklich nur der
neubau und die förderung des neubaus und
dazu muss man auch kreative maßnahmen
ergreifen wie zum beispiel dass man
schaut welche dachgeschosse können
ausgebaut werden wo kann zusätzlicher
wohnraum geschaffen werden und
gleichzeitig mit einer vereinbarung
gekoppelt um gegebenenfalls dann in
darunter liegenden wohnung zb beat
preisgebundenen wohnraum anzubieten
wir brauchen ein baulückenkataster um
auch aktiv auf sie dazu zu bewegen bei
den hervorragenden bedingungen die wir
gerade haben bei den niedrigen zinsen
das auszunutzen und günstigen wohnraum
zu schaffen
genauso kann aber wie ich eben andeutete
auch der mieter selber zum eigentümer
gemacht werden wir haben wenn wir uns
durchschnittliche bau oder reise in ein
wohn geschäftshaus anschauen und schmidt
vor gekauft werden dann ist der
quadratmeterpreis bei 3500 euro
wenn man das mit einem prozent rechnet
dann würde ein mieter der die wohnung
für 3500 euro gekauft und da drei euro
nettokaltmiete praktisch nur den
zinssatz zahlen und würde langfristig
eigentümer werden können also eine
historisch einmalige in berlin die
mieter wirklich zu eigentümer zu machen
wenn sie denn den rücktritt von frau
lompscher jetzt richtig und konsequent
auf jeden fall was sie getan hat ist ein
eine steuerhinterziehung trotzdem finde
ich hatte so ein bisschen das
geschmäckle wie das jemand ein
strafzettel zugibt in wirklichkeit aber
bankräuber ist und der berliner senat
der rot rot grünen senat berlin angetan
hat das sind millionenschäden und da
sind auch wenn es ein hoher betrag ist
aber da ist die steuerhinterziehung und
das was da mit dem steuer oder dem
bürger in berlin entgangen ist
lächerlich